في هذه العملية من الآن فصاعدًا ، نعلم
أنه فقط من التجربة السابقة السابقة
لتاريخ المحكمة الجنائية الدولية ، يمكن أن يستغرق هذا
سنوات طويلة جدًا حتى يرى أي شيء
ضوء النهار من حيث التجربة ،
ما رأيك في ذلك ،
نعم هذا صحيح  لذا ، في الوقت الحالي ، من
غير الواضح حقًا متى ستتم المحاكمة ،
أعني أن هذا الخبر قد اندلع للتو ، ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالمحكمة الجنائية الدولية ، يتعين على الشخص أن يظهر
شخصيًا حتى تحدث المحاكمة بالفعل ،
وهذا أمر مهم حقًا هنا
لأنه الآن هناك مذكرة التوقيف هذه
من أجل الرئيس بوتين ، وهي
أخبار مهمة للغاية ،
سيكون بقية العالم في حالة تأهب حتى يتم
القبض عليه بشكل أساسي كلما
سافر خارج روسيا ، ولكن
طالما بقي في روسيا ، فسوف يحافظ على
الإفلات من العقاب وهذا شيء
لوزارة الخارجية.  أشار المسؤولون إلى
أن هذا أحد التحديات لمحاولة
محاكمة شخص على هذا المستوى الرفيع
محمي بحدود
بلده وأعتقد أيضًا أنه من
المهم ملاحظة أنك تعرف أحد
الأشياء التي
كان مسؤولو وزارة الخارجية  المراقبة هنا هي
من تقرر المحكمة الجنائية الدولية ملاحقة حقيقة
أنهم يلاحقون الرئيس
بوتين هو خبر رئيسي هنا ولكن هناك
أيضًا هذه المرأة الأخرى
المسؤولة عن برنامج الأطفال في
روسيا والتي تسعى وراءها أيضًا  من
المحتمل أن
تسافر خارج البلاد ويمكن أن
يضعوا أيديهم عليها الآن
لم نسمع بعد بالطبع ردًا
من وزارة الخارجية ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بعلاقة الولايات المتحدة مع
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية ، فإن الولايات المتحدة ليست كذلك  طرف في المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
النظام الأساسي الذي أنشأ المحكمة الجنائية الدولية ولكن
تاريخياً كان هناك نوع من
العلاقة المثيرة للجدل بين الولايات المتحدة
والمحكمة الجنائية الدولية خلال
إدارة بايدن ، لكنهم
انخرطوا بالفعل مع بعضهم البعض وهذا
ما تسمعه يتحدث عنه مسؤولو وزارة الخارجية
ولذا من الواضح أنني أعتقد أن هذا
شيء سيرحبون به
لأن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
نشهد فيها بالفعل اتهامات
وجهت مذكرة توقيف بشأن جرائم جرائم
الحرب التي
ارتكبت في أوكرانيا لأن
وزارة الخارجية قالت إن
التصميم هو أن القوات الروسية
قد ارتكبت جرائم حرب ولكن ليس
لديها في الواقع القدرة على توجيه
اتهامات في محكمة قانونية وهذا هو السبب في أن
هذا أمر مهم للغاية.